tiens merci merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de l'éducation nationale madame
la ministre il y a 6 mois vous êtes
venue à vesoul en grande pompe avec vos
collègues du gouvernement avec le
premier ministre avec le président de la
république pour nous parler de ruralité
et six mois plus tard le conseil
départemental socialiste ferme quatre
collèges ruraux
le collège jérôme juste devant la
préfecture et le collège de champlitte
notamment qui fermera dès le mois de
septembre prochain
voilà un bel exemple d'escroquerie
politique de la part de ce gouvernement
de belles phrases de belles phrases dans
les colloques dans les conférences ici
même à une réalité bien différente sur
le terrain partout en france des
collèges ruraux ferme et vous ne dites
rien est ce par complaisance ou par
complicité
surtout lorsqu'il s'agit d'élus locaux
socialistes aux demandes des élus locaux
vous n'avez même pas daigné répondre par
madame la ministre un peu de cohérence
si on défend la ruralité on demande aux
élus locaux y compris socialistes et
surtout socialiste veut maintenir les
collèges en milieu rural alors madame la
ministre
êtes vous prête à vous battre aux côtés
des parents d'élèves des enseignants qui
souhaitent le maintien de leurs collèges
ruraux à champlitte comme ailleurs êtes
vous prête à vous opposer à la fermeture
des collèges ruraux
la parole est à madame najat vallaud
belkacem mini the education nationale de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
alain chrétien je pense que ce serait
vous faire injure que vous rappelez de
qui est la compétence la construction
des collèges l'entretien des collèges la
carte scolaire qui compte
les collèges donc c'est de la compétence
des conseils départementaux et donc le
conseil départemental que vous évoquez a
pour des raisons que j'imagine d'ordre
démographique décidé de fermer un
certain nombre d'établissements si il y
à un dialogue à ouvrir je pense que
c'est avec ce conseil départemental mais
peut-être avez-vous commencé à le faire
pour ce qui nous concerne ministère de
l'éducation nationale nous veillons dans
ce type de décision à ce que bien sûr
les calendriers respecte à la fois la
scolarité des élèves et la gestion des
personnels dont vous pouvez vous assurer
que le recteur de besançon y veille et
aussi à ce que la question de la mixité
sociale soit bien prise en compte
maintenant je peux vous parler puisque
votre question était plus générale de ce
sur quoi j'ai compétences en effet
l'état le ministère l'éducation
nationale a compétence pour les écoles
et donc les et l'école dans les
territoires ruraux je peux vous dire en
effet les efforts importants que nous
faisons qui ont été d'ailleurs complété
par le tout dernier comité
interministériel à la ruralité qui s'est
tenue en ardèche vendredi dernier je
vous confirme par exemple que comme je
voulais souvent annoncés ici nous avons
proposé à tous les départements ruraux
de france qui jusqu'àlors été piégé
puisque à chaque rentrée scolaire
lorsqu'ils voyaient leurs effectifs
démographique b c est bien ça se
traduisait par une fermeture de classes
voire d'écoles
nous leur avons proposé de nous engager
dans un conventionnement avec le
ministère de l'éducation nationale qui
nous conduit à neutraliser ces
fermetures de classes ou d'écoles
pendant trois ans trois ans pendant
lesquels avec les élus locaux de ces
départements nous travaillons à une
réorganisation territoriale intelligente
dans le sens de l'intérêt des enfants
notamment par des regroupements
pédagogiques intercommunaux
ils sont déjà quinze départements ruraux
avoir signé ces conventions de tous les
partis d'ailleurs de tous les bords
politiques
ils seront 25 de plus à le faire à la
rentrée prochaine a terminé nous en
restera plus que 20 à couvrir notre sac
sur votre territoire séance des
questions au gouvernement
et terminer la séance est suspendue nous